أطلب إشعار العمل العام
للحركة رقم 388
السناتور أه المياه ستنتقل إلى 388.
آه شكرًا نائب الرئيس ، أطلب أن يتم اعتبار
إشعار العمل العام للحركة رقم
388 التي تقف باسمي اليوم
فيما يتعلق بمرض الرئة السوداء
كحركة رسمية لذلك
السؤال هو أن الحركة تحركت من قبل
السناتور المياه
أه أوافق على من يؤيدون ذلك الرأي ،
وأرجو أن يتم أخذ العفو الخاص بك كحركة رسمية
أم نعم ليس هناك اعتراض على ذلك
بالنسبة لي لقد حركت الاقتراح لذا
السناتور ماكغراث  الإدلاء ببيان قصير
كإجازة ممنوحة إذا تم منح دقيقة واحدة ،
فإن الحكومة لا تدعم هذه
الحركة.تشخيص الرئة السوداء بين
محيطات عمال الفحم
ولديهم المنظمون الخاصون بهم لمراقبة
الامتثال القسري
على الرغم من أن الكومنولث لا
ينظم سلامة التعدين ، فإنه يستمر في ذلك
العمل مع حكومات الولايات والأقاليم
لحمايتك